voici l'avis d'une ex mari sur le tapis
plus blind test tous les tubes qui
cartonne depuis qu'il fait des tubes le
nouveau dj servait alors là et jean-luc
matricule 65 rtp 515 de la dass dessous
dirk auer tp recueilli temporaire
provisoire tu as toujours su qu'ils
arriveraient je pensais que c'était hors
de ma portée mais tu pouvais m'en
approcher le plus possible
je pensais que en créant si tu veux le
hasard la teinte les esprits préparés
mais j'avais tout fait pour me situer
sur la même sur le même chemin qu'eux ou
à prier la télé non content de le
réussir la chanson tu dé lancer dans la
télé c'est curieux la façon dont je suis
arrivée sur tf1 est une chaîne qui
devenait privé tout le monde était parti
sur l'a5
il fallait absolument monter une grille
rapidement avant l'été bon mon nom
et vu comme ça je suis venu chanter papa
chanteur à francis boy il a trouvé que
le texte était intéressant il m'a
demandé si ça pouvait marcher j'ai dit
que ça marche et il m'a demandé de
chanter deux couplets ouais tu entends
j'ai pas entendu la phrase d'avancer
quoi la juste et vendues aux mamans
douceur assez bien il me prenait des
notes passer très très bien maman
douceur et alors ça va ça va marcher ça
ou bien alors il dit très très bien et
le blue jeans que vous avez sur vous
vous allez garder très probablement à
vous allez faire de la tv en blue jeans
se situe certainement bon si vous voulez
et quand je suis parti du bureau j'étais
convaincu que je ferai pas de télé et
que c'était mieux comme ça c'est vrai
les trois jours après on m'a appelé en
font signer d'urgence
quand j'ai signé sans trop réfléchir
parce que si j'avais eu un peu de recul
j'aurais jamais signé j'aurais préféré
débarquer à gauche ont été débarqués
mois sur une pirogue la télé je t'admire
parfum et puis bon ben j'ai fait sa une
la neva ouais sans plus quand avait
déclaré au début de l'émission dans une
interview si tu avais dit si j'étais
resté que chanteur je serai mal et la
malle en tant que chanteur du sang
comment jouer
je suis libre je suis heureux ça va as
tu veux pas savoir ce que tu viens de
faire un tube 1 me suis ravie chemin
pour plein de choses à plein tube qui
s'appelle tu es parti sans laisser de
tendresse